our change agents I think we can we can
safely say after our conversation their
work deals with place and identity and
creating spaces where wisdom a belief
can arise and people can work together
collaboratively I'm going to just give
you a little bit of background on both
of our speakers tonight
Gabrielle bender Vianney is an urbanist
photographer and curator professor of
urban studies at the new school and
co-founder of the interdisciplinary
black practice on place in dialogue with
SCADA through which he creates projects
that engender dialogue between
communities individuals and disciplines
to explore critical questions place and
visual urbanism i'm shields a doctorate
and environmental psychology from the
Graduate Center CUNY and is a visiting
fellow at the Center for urban and
community research Goldsmith's
University London she has worked on
projects internationally and has
exhibited at places such as creative
timing Centre for architecture over at
Parsons MIT UC Berkeley and the Agron's
Art Center and her room
has been reviewed in many prestigious
journals and she also is the co-founder
of the urban encounters conference rural
sorry for original world visual urbanism
held at the Tate and Ruth is welcome we
work on her back she spoke into our
fieldwork this makes big projects that
harness technical prowess for community
engagement and social transformation
thank you kindly provided me with this
she has created chalk an annual
community commemoration of the Triangle
Shirtwaist Fire which began in 2005 for
voices of 911 project many of you know
here without we're over 550 video
testimonies in New York Shanksville
Pennsylvania inside the Pentagon talked
about people talked about their
experiences to turn 11
it's also been exhibited at the Corcoran
for award-winning films have been
screened at the MoMA on PBS and FBI of
seeker here Ruth's interactive
documentaries have been exhibited in the
US and Europe and the magic box was
created with the support of the
experimental television Center which I
my favorite project that alchemy of
light is equally beautiful Ruth has a
wonderful website you can see many of
her projects there she was a visiting
fellow in public humanities at Brown
University and has presented her work
for the at the national center for
public humanities and cultural heritage
she's worked who work has been covered
extensively in the New York Times CNN
National Public Radio and she was
honored on either guest at the White
House and Ruth's work was on featured
and on CNN this weekend so give me a I'm
sorry Gabrielle Gabrielle looking at you
Briana I've your work intersector sighs
away and it worked on the triangle fire
project so I hope you did we can talk a
little bit about that but please thank
you for having us so start off and what
I'd like to do is to present two
projects you guys um around this kind of
idea of thinking about public projects
as ways of making space for dialogue so
and these two projects are projects that
I've been working on for significant
number of years this one particularly
was been a four year project and they're
looking at two different sites where
something happened quite a while ago at
this point so the first one is the
Seward Park urban renewal area and
that's this project called the layered
Smyrna project um the second site that's
what it looks like now and my second
site is the ash building in Greenwich
Village in New York talking about the
triangle fire open museum just to give
you a little background on what these
two sites are to give you a little
history about kind of
where we are Seward Park urban renewal
areas on the lower Eastside if any of
you are familiar with the Williamsburg
Bridge you have gone past this site and
mostly it's a lot of parking lots right
now and it it was a 14 square block area
that was slated for urban renewal and
demolition in 1967 and almost 2,000
families were displaced from this area
this was what it looked like this is
actually from the promotional literature
that was the plan for the urban renewal
so you can see that they were
highlighting look wealdian rid of these
terrible tenements which you know now
bred for six thousand dollars a month
two blocks away but we'll get rid of
these and we're gonna build something
much better but what actually happened
was nothing got that and so that's a
part of this history many of the people
who were displaced were families of
color most of them low-income and what
was promised and what was planned was
for it to be a moderate and low income
the context is that 40 more than 40
years later very little new has actually
been built on this site so there are
have been a few buildings that have been
built since the that and the demolition
actually took close to 15 years so
people lived with the kind of
displacement and then the scar of
watching their neighborhood deteriorate
over 15 years so that's the context for
this site and then of course you guys so
this is sort of what it looks like if
you're looking at it sort of
romantically through the chain-link
fence with the morning glories but you
can see that parking lots and the very
few buildings that were actually built
so this is a very different site site of
the triangle fire mate we can think
about this site as another important
where another kind of very important and
significant piece of New York City
history happened so 1911 we're talking
about now and we're talking about the
context of labor history labor activism
the kind of organizing that was
happening around the time of the of the
fire the kind of labor conditions that
were in existence at the time so a very
very different kind of context but a
very similarly interconnected kind of
event so connected to much larger
questions if spur is connected to larger
histories of race in this country of
larger questions of Housing and inequity
the triangle fire is really connected to
much larger questions about
labor rights women's rights immigrants
rights right so that we can sort of see
these two sites on these two projects as
being very very specific but also very
sites of really two tragedies in New
York history but also with very complex
histories that have very many larger
issues that are embedded within the
specifics of their histories and that's
kind of why I wanted to talk about the
two of them together today and why the
projects that I want to present really
focus on looking at these narratives as
a way of telling through making space
for dialogue to talk through the
complexity of these of these past
histories and one of the things that I'm
really always extremely Comus in that is
the idea that many many diverse
communities are affected by both of
these sites of both of these histories
and most often these are very divergent
communities who are impacted by these
two sites and these two histories with
very divergent interests and very
divergent needs and in this kind of
practice in this kind of work that is
thinking about how do we not only
imagine kind of the different roles of
who's involved in the site and
understanding its history but also how
do we think about public projects on how
do we bring multiple communities back
together this idea of making a space for
dialogue I think we have to be very
cognizant of defining what community is
and one of the things that I found is
that very too often I would say in
engaged or collaborative projects the
idea of community is taken to simply or
to positively and it really makes me he
need all of this work really makes me
he'd Raymond Williams this morning which
i think is really quite excellent that
community can be the warmly persuasive
word to describe an existing
of relationships or to describe an
alternative set of relationships but
what's most important perhaps is that
unlike all other terms of social
organization state nation society all of
those words it seems to never be used
unfavorably I think we can really look
to think about this idea of taking apart
what community needs and I think that's
a big part of the kind of practice that
I mean both groups and Micawber's are
engaged in and sort of looking
critically at it so just to introduce
jump in to introduce that first project
these projects together really because
of this idea of the complexity of these
kinds of community that are embedded in
these two sites and these two really
complex histories with divergent points
of view and divergent ideas of claims
made to them so the first one the
layered Sparrow project so this is what
the map of that area looks like now you
can remember that all those tenements
were in that picture well you can't
really see it at all actually
Oh where'd it show south of billion see
down to Grand East from Essex over to
Pitt Street what was 14 square blocks of
tenements so this is what it looks like
now you can see how very few buildings
are actually on that site and this idea
of what murid should have mentioned in
my bio in terms of talking about this
idea of a practice of visual urbanism is
what I'm really interested in using to
unpack some of these really complex
ideas on these complex sites so this
parcel of land is not only the site of
this really complex history and would
really explore tragedy of displacement
in the late 50s but it's also located at
this very potent kind of intersection
and parcel of land at the Lower East
Side right so it's kind of the
intersection of the historically Jewish
Chinese and Puerto Rican Lower East
Side's and it really has a very
important kind of connection for all of
those communities and so when my
students take their first walkthrough
Saburo they always have this kind of
shock of the wilderness and also of
recognition so it's a very complicated
and hard to understand place visually
it's hard to make sense of it but it's
also a place that you've all sort of
been to before and maybe turned away
from and sort of walked around and so I
began this project in 2008 through a
class I teach at the new school called
City
studio and I develop the class as a way
to look at this site and to understand
its context now and to understand the
nuances of its history and to use a kind
of hybrid approach of pedagogy and
activism kind of art and research and to
train students to sort of see this space
in a new way and to use it as a way to
bring a complex kind of collaboration
between students and community
organizations so and my students really
engage in practices that lead us to make
things that look like this so how do we
kind of use this history and engage with
this history and why make something that
ends up being an exhibition to ask some
kinds of complex questions about these
important and kind of contradictory
histories that are embedded there so
part of what we do is to really engage
with the complexity of what this idea of
community is and so you know at some
point when I work with with students
there's always a point in which they
have struggled in they've learned this
history they've read oral histories
they've started to talk with people in
community meetings at community
visioning sessions they've read a whole
history of housing and inequity in New
York City and they at some point think
there is really nothing we can do here
and they throw up their hands to a
certain extent because they wonder how
they can a bring some sort of new
perspective to this community struggle
and also how do they engage with a site
it's not their home and so that's
something that through this process has
been really important to think about
kind of grounding ourselves in sites
histories so using ways of engaging with
really deep community participation
taking part in and being useful to
community visioning sessions that have
happened over the last four years part
lot having long-term partnerships with
community organizations such as goals
good old Lower East Side coalition
activists like choose for racial and
economic justice so sort of building a
broad base of collaboration and kind of
understanding through the community so
that's been a really important part this
idea that through these kinds of long
term practices because I've been working
on this project for four years that we
build trust over that period of time and
I think we've really also sort of
developed ideas both sort of within the
class and as a practice and also in
collaboration with our community
partners about what art practices
whatever that might mean can do in this
context of community activism and that's
I think been a really interesting and
important part of the project so
we spend a lot of time brainstorming
ways to think about well what impact are
the goals of doing this kind of work you
know how do you actually include voices
how do you think about the possibilities
how do you kind of make something that
is open rather than closed my students
go through process these are mostly
students who are not part students over
not design students so they often the
idea of making form from rich kinds of
in-depth research is very alien to them
so the practice of building in what is a
critique and and how do you kind of make
things Ruth and I were just talking
earlier with students and one of the
things that we were talking about was
you know how do you get things funded
well one of the things ways I think we
get things but is is by actually making
things and showing a project and so this
is also part of this is like this idea
of processes of making so you have lots
of critiques lots of trying things out
and lots of ways of just thinking
through how do you make visual these
very complex questions about a site that
is highly contested and and highly
divided so thinking about making maps so
this has led to a series of exhibitions
so in local areas so in the local area
and neighborhood community centers so
this one was a common room a small
gallery space this one was also there
and you can see these projects that are
extraordinarily kind of interactive that
we try to look at qualities of this
space so one of the the goals of this
work has not been to suggest what should
happen on this site which is these kind
of open parking lots that are this is
also the should say the largest city
owned plot of land and
you're south of 96th Street it's an
incredibly valuable portion of land and
it was very large and so there are many
people who have a lot of very divergent
ideas about what should happen here and
one of the goals of this project has
always been not to say what should
happen here but how to open up the
conversation to ask questions about what
could happen here as a way of suggesting
that the multiple communities involved
could actually sort of use this spaces
of these exhibitions to talk with each
other aprons Art Center one of the
things that has been exciting and sort
of surprising has been that many of our
community partners are home they're
always there at these openings and they
have said you know I've never actually
seen this group of people in this room
together not screaming at each other
so it's also been about the ways in
which a practice that has been very
engaged and sort of nuanced and trying
to get in depth to the history the kind
of pulling out of people's stories how
can we present that back to the
community in a way that people can sort
of think about the actual specifics of
the site rather than kind of their own
an ideological position or what they're
kind of coming into it with this Art
Center people kind of looking at this
project that was called framings borough
which students really tried to show the
different ways and the different kind of
imaginations that have been made for
this space to show kind of how very very
different and have very many many kinds
of imagined futures there has been a
divergent imagined futures there have
been for this site we took part in the
creative time living as form a good
vision and really sort of used it as an
opportunity we had a little booth and
used it as an opportunity to talk with
people this is actually at the edge of
that site when we ended up talking with
many people who had no idea of this
history and so another way that this
form of this project has has actually
happened is not just through the
exhibitions but thinking about other
ways of making space for dialogue so I
created a series of walking tours as
well so participants in these walking
tours are given one of these layered
Spira cards and for each card I kinda
that has that image on a quote about
some aspect of the history or spur it's
almost like they're sort of cue cards
for its history and so as I lead people
through this space there's me in October
and I'll kind of intervals I call on
people to read their part they're their
cards allowed so it's also about kind of
thinking about the ways in which the
voices of these histories can be brought
back into this physical space itself and
so they're on the street we kind of take
turns embodying these really conflicting
voices as far as past and present so as
the group leans into one young woman
brings us the voice of an elderly man
long ago pushed out of Spira an older
man on the tour an older man on the tour
reads the voice of a woman who fears
what affordable housing quote unquote
will do to her newly purchased coops
property values a student at the local
high school reads from the 1973 court
transcripts of the racial discrimination
class-action lawsuits that were bought
brought against the two public housing
buildings
were actually built on the site when
they opened so this portion of the
project is not just kind of creating
spaces for dialogue through exhibition
sites but also kind of amongst a one
specific small group kind of in the
practice of walking and inserting that
into of space we're in that kind of
physical space where these kinds of
conversations I've been really sorely
lacking so this is what happened this
year was a culmination of four years of
this practice this is and this was the
first time that this work was actually
shown outside of the community this was
at the new school and so one of the
things that was quite interesting to me
was to think about well how can this be
another sort of space and so you know
who are the audiences and who are the
communities that are kind of coming to
this space as opposed to these other
spaces as well looking at it and you
know one of the things that happen at
the opening was someone asked me what
the eventual goal of this project was
and I realized that really quite simply
and I think my answer sort of surprised
her I said well actually that it's
really simply having people together in
this room talking about this question
and that answers to what should happen
in this kind of contested site really
have to come from within the community
but that without a space for having a
dialogue around that there's really no
way to get to that point so this is one
of the comments left at the exhibition
and so I just want to kind of shift
gears a little and to show you a small
portion of the the triangle fire open
archive an open museum project to kind
of show a different way of taking this
approach and so here we are back at the
ash building you know we're jumping back
in time to 1911 it feels like a very
divergent kind of question you know
thinking about the history of this fire
that was so incredibly destructive to
the people who were inside this building
but actually not to the building itself
you know and thinking about you know why
is it still relevant well 2010 we have a
similar kind of fire happening in
Bangladesh we have questions about labor
organizing we have questions about you
know Scott Walker banning unions all of
this kind of thing that's happening
right now so how do we sort of think
about the larger questions embedded in
both of these sites as a reason for
investigating them and as a reason for
instigating kinds of dialogue around
them so you know thinking about well
this is the this is what they trying to
fire open our kind of looks like so how
can a form that looks like this a
virtual online space and I'm really
addressed some of those sorts of
questions so the project really takes
this very participatory and
collaborative approach and it's a
collaboration between the remember the
triangle fire coalition which Ruth will
certainly talk about Ruth is the founder
of that coalition and vez cada mine
organization and so one of the things
that was so phenomenal and as we sort of
think about kind of definitions of
community was to think about well who
was involved in this coalition on how
incredibly broad and amazing those
conversations were that happened between
these groups of people and so one of the
things that we really wanted to do was
to take an approach that
is some aspect of the fact that all of
these people were getting together in a
room or around thinking about this the
triangle fire or Centennial and to think
about well can objects tell stories can
those objects stand in for these
multiple perspectives that works are
being brought into the room and so we
created this open archive which is an
online space through that of community
contributed objects that we asked people
to just contribute objects that they
thought for some reason told some
portion of a triangle fire story or the
significance of it today and so you know
really thinking about this idea that
stories become embodied once they're
sort of embedded in objects that they
become much more tangible and much more
understandable when we can kind of use
the idea of the object as a way to
explore them and to bring in these
multiple ways of participation so
collecting objects in person but also
online thinking about the different
kinds of objects that can tell stories
of personal objects and public objects
doing research on very little documented
kind of work so very personal objects
like the Rosie Weiner portrait collected
from her great niece and so this is a
photograph of something that sits on her
mantelpiece or our bookshelf extra and
and so that becomes part of this archive
and this is what it looks like in the
upper drive itself or objects like a
newsletter from the 1982 Chinatown
Gardner
so how's it having nothing to do so I
should say Rosie Wiener was a victim of
the triangle fire
you know then we dropped forward to 1982
what does that have to do with 1911
right it has something to do with the
larger questions that are at stake than
that are at stake now and certainly also
were the the local that actually came
out so this is sort of gathering these
objects in person photographing them and
then also have letting them live online
and and live online in their sort of
contradictory ways together the project
that's come out of this work this year
is the open museum and that and you guys
can pick up these booklets they're all
back there it's a way of taking these
objects offline and bringing them back
into the tangible world and to think
about how can we insert them back into
people's experience so rather than you
having to go to the online archive how
can you kind of find these things around
the city itself so we borrowed objects
back from people or we made replicas and
this is what these things look like and
they're right now all around the city in
six different sites so five which are
there are pictures of here so tenement
museum you go and find these little
orange boxes and and sort of go find the
the narratives and the histories that
people have connected to the physical
objects in the online archive you can
find them here but you can actually see
that physical physical objects
at the murky scent Institute at CUNY
this is workers United and fi T so also
these are really important sites that
tell you something not only about New
York's history or because they happen to
be kind of nice places to go and see
things or because they're having to be
open to the public but there are also
sites that talk about these larger
questions that are invented in the
Triangle fire itself in a contemporary
context right so my Museum of Chinese
America has an image of that right so
you can think about the ways in which
we're sort of bringing these objects out
into the world and one of the things
that we've been really interested in is
the ways in which sort of situating
objects in the world can actually then
lead to further conversation around to
using the objects themselves and really
one of the things that I just wanted to
kind of highlight is this idea of this
sort of public projects as making space
for dialogue right so that and acting as
a kind of bridge so between City sites
and institutions that are in and of
themselves really significant but also
between aspects of public memory public
practice public history so to use these
both these two projects as a ways of
making connections between this and and
in that in that connection that the
point of it is to get people to talk
around these sites and to make spaces
for that kind of talk to happen so
thinking about that these are very
different kinds of you talk in different
kinds of dialogic practice but I see a
lot of connections between them and I
think particularly in their basis around
kind of nuanced richness of personal
histories as being the basis
these sorts of projects and the fact
that you know there is something that
you can take away from both projects and
use those things to explore the city and
see the city itself in a different way
to sort and search yourself in a new way
into those dialects as well
thirty seconds more will be there
hi and thanks especially to the students
in boarding who did the pre two hours
doing the long haul run I think what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna try to blaze
through an overview of a lot of work
that I've made because mostly what I'd
like to talk about is it's sort of
bigger issues than any specific projects
and kind of what I'd like to start with
this you know I've sort of reached a
point where my I feel very strongly that
I like to try to create projects that
for people just by participating in them
they are empowered and have that
experience rather than me telling them
they should be empowered which I don't
think is particularly effective but it's
taking me many many projects to sort of
evolve an experiment with that and
things that worked and things that have
not worked very well so I'm just gonna
go through a bunch of those projects
very quickly my background is actually
in film production my my father my
father's side of the family has been in
theater for a bazillion years and my
stepfather is an eight-by-ten view
camera photographer so I thought I was
gonna rebel by going into the film and
only many years later did I realize it
was complete of those two so I started
off by making films and by sort of a
mixture of working with people and
putting my vision on it so I'm gonna
show you just very quickly because this
relates to something we were talking
about earlier we were asked about
mistakes and things that did not go well
and I had done a project which went
horribly wrong and not horribly but not
so great and so I made this film in
response to that it's just three minutes
I hope everything works technically and
if not we'll improvise
so what I learned from this project was
mostly what was surprising to me was
that when I started sending it out to
festivals I started getting an
inordinate number of questions about was
Bruce Jackson actually disabled or not
and it was really shocking to me that
people would ask that because it was so
clear to me that yes he has cerebral
palsy and he's disabled and I didn't
really know where that was coming from
and then I had a great conversation with
dr. he say Barnwell of sweet honey in
the rock who do the song and I mentioned
it to her and she was like Ruth you have
to understand people have compartments
in their brain and they have one
compartment for grace and beauty and
another compartment for disability and
they just cannot concede that they would
be matched together and that was a real
eye-opener to me about how narrow the
portrayal of our lives that we see in
our day-to-day lives and it's so easy to
just step out of that if you tell
anything truthful about yourself you
pretty much fall out of what is in the
accepted dialog so that was a really
great clue for me and I went on to start
making films where I would do a lot of
research and then write the script and
then I would go find the population that
was depicted in my work and I would not
show them the script but I would tell
them the story of the film and then we
would workshop for many many weeks on
the themes and ideas when we would do
improvisation and theater games just
talking about the issues and I would
videotape it and then I would take their
language and put it back into the
structure of the script I had already
created and then we would go and
shoot these films and it was a very
traditional 35 millimeter shoot so they
were thrown out of the whole comfortable
room of a workshop process for the shoot
and I was in the midst of doing that and
I started to notice some problems for
myself which was that I was creating
these bonus because I wanted to create a
transformative experience for the
audience and when I would go to screams
I always would sit at the front by the
side and I would turn and I'd watch the
audience cuz I've seen the movie I
didn't care and I would look at
different people to see how they were
responding in different moments and then
you sort of realized like when you've
made a film you're stuck like it's
always gonna be the same film you can't
change you can't do anything and the
same time in a sense the audience is
stuck because you're saying you want to
transform them but at the same time
you're asking them to sit silently and
still in the dark and to be polite and
good in all those very constricting ways
and I began to be think about ways that
we could maybe break out of that model
but in the midst of that a 911 happened
and I began volunteering down at here's
New Yorker democracy of photographs
which opened just days later on Prince
Street and Soho and what they did is
they would take people could bring in
photographs that related to 9/11 and we
would scan them and print them and then
hang them on the wall and there was
hundreds of photographs shown and it
became a like a makeshift memorial and
also as time progressed a safe place for
people to engage with their feelings
about 9/11 so you wanted to think about
9/11
other people who were thinking about it
you could come to this place and in fact
there was lines around the block for
people who needed that safe space in the
time after that and I started there as a
volunteer photo editor in early October
and what that meant is I would sit at a
table and people would come to me and
sometimes they were just like dumped
like hundreds of photographs and we
would sort through them to find the few
that would be contributed and I noticed
that there was really interesting things
happening in the stories people were
telling one is that especially in the
early days the stories were extremely
shattered and often did not make a
logical sense at that point and also
that people would come back and they
would say literally identical things
because they wanted me to say of
identical things in response that then
they could go back and correct their
story as they were starting to piece
things together and I also noticed that
some people were getting silenced and
that was particularly clear with the
fire fighters at first they had been
very open and talking to people and then
my interpretation is that a lot of them
had the experience of they were supposed
to be the heroes so they would talk to
some whatever interviewee interviewer
about their experience and then that
interview would be shown but it would be
edited and the edited version is that
they are a hero and they did some heroic
wonderful thing on 9/11 but their actual
experience of it was often much more sad
and and that community is very
collaborative and you are not supposed
to put yourself first before others and
so that interview would be
in this model of heroism and then their
buddies are like what the heck are you
doing like saying this stuff and they're
like well I didn't say it that way and
they're like but we saw it on TV and you
did and so they were in and so then they
just shut up because they didn't want to
show their stories so I was thinking
about stories being the first way that
we can own our own experience of these
kinds of events and so I decided to
create this project voices of 9/11 and
we built a booth
I used as a model get the old photo
booths where you get the strips when you
sit there and you do your poses and get
things because I thought that was
something people feel comfortable with
and one thing I'll say about this
project is that I think a number of
people since then have asked me how I
did this project technically and I'm
always happy to share and tell everyone
exactly how I did it but then I always
say the technology do not make the
project it was that environment we
created around it that made it
successful and then they copy the
technology and they don't do the
environment and then their projects
don't work so if you want to make a
video booth I think there was some
really important things about how we did
this project the first is in the first
versions of the video booth they were in
the heros New York galleries so people
were already there in that space that
created a particular environment
she made they also had to make an
appointment to speak in the booth so
they've already bought through to some
degree or another what they were gonna
say later once we got to the Pentagon
for example we were essentially in a
mall and the Pentagon um but it was okay
because that by then we had enough
experience to carry people through but
we had a very specific process for
people who came to
and that was one of the first things we
did because you had to fill out a
release form was the person who brought
you through signing the release and
going through the process was instructed
to acknowledge wherever that perspi ker
was coming from so if they lost somebody
you would acknowledge that they had lost
somebody if they had if they were a
survivor you would say that you were so
sorry that they had this experience and
you're so grateful for them to
participate in this you because a lot of
people when you've experienced trauma
you need to tell the story so many times
to kind of push it and shove it into a
shape that you can live with and very
often it's many more times than the
people in your life can actually hear
that story and so we will so you start
to constrict yourself and we wanted to
create a space where people could open
themselves again to whatever they needed
to express about this story so I'm just
going to show you the booth for now this
is the booth set up in the Pentagon
at a certain point we had when people
came out of the booth we would give them
a sharpie and they could read something
on the outside of me so it's like not a
pretty checked we did the whole voices
project for probably for the recordings
probably like 50 or $60,000 we recorded
about 550 testimonies here in New York
City we went to Shanksville Pennsylvania
we're in the Corcoran Gallery of Art in
Washington DC for the one-year
anniversary and then we were inside the
Pentagon for three weeks and my
experience was that people were very
specific in what they wanted to share
mostly they wanted to share things that
you could not know unless you would
experience something like this so I'm
going to show a very very very short
clip from one of the speakers from
then I realized that that there were
people jumping from the building there
were people falling and there were
people jumping in and and every single
one of them was different
these were not this wasn't just
something going out the building or
every single individual it was different
with every single individual the the
language of the follow the language of
the body it expressed something
different some some were helpless and
some were were terrified and and some
were so defiant like I'm if my Luck's
ending that I'm ending it defiant and
but every one of them was who they were
and and I I can fill many more after
that so I turned the camera off
so once that project was created I feel
like if it's not that I only do projects
about people dying going out of
buildings but I have been long obsessed
with the triangle fire I grew up in New
York City and I think you grow up with
this story here and I always wanted to
make something about it but I could not
think of a way to do it and every couple
of years I've come back to it and I
thought I should make a movie and every
idea I had was like incredibly schmaltzy
and stupid and just like oh and so I
would have to release it and then years
later try again and still nothing and
then fortunately in 2004 David bond
rally his wonderful book triangle to
fire that changed America came out and
in the back he listed the names and the
ages and the addresses of the victims of
the fire and I just felt in my heart
something so strong when I read that
list and and also I had a film this is
the real stories I had a film that was
about to open at a big festival and I
was very nervous so I wanted to distract
myself so I emailed about 30 friends of
mine and just said hey I have this crazy
idea how about if on the anniversary of
the Triangle Shirtwaist Factory fire we
all go out to the victims homes and we
write and chalk their names their ages
that they lived at this address and they
drive it died in the Triangle Shirtwaist
Factory fire and even that first year
those emails just got dispersed many
many steps removed and and now and I
didn't think of it anything beyond this
first initial project and now this past
year was the ninth year of the project
and people are much more creative than I
ever was they do drawings they do
rituals
now many people who live in
buildings like to chalk the person who
lived in their building family members
chalk their their family members of
Stanton Street shul likes to pick a
victim and then do a lot of research in
them they made it like a community vent
event on Clinton Street this year so
it's taken on a life of its own and I
think in part it's because I don't
control it we never have a meeting but
I've never met many of the chakras
they've never met many of each other I
have like somebody else to say oh I want
to chalk this person I always talk this
person who lived in my building and if
you want I'll do the person who lived
across the street because we always
imagined they walked just to work
together and I'm like you can't do the
person across the street because the
person in that building likes to chalk
their person so it's been an ongoing and
and I feel like there's been an organic
development of the project where people
have really taken possession of certain
names that they feel very this year
somebody lived in the building was going
to be out of town so they got somebody
else in their building to cover for them
and these kinds of things are happening
now and next you'll be the 10th year so
I think I'm going to finally make
something so we can all meet each other
just once but I don't even know exactly
and so through doing this I I became
very aware of the diversity of
communities that feel very personally
passionate about the triangle fire and
one of the things that I think I was
thinking about out of the 911 project
was how can we get along with what I
called hard tolerance so not the easy
tolerance of all we should all get along
and everything should be fine but what
about when you would hit those walls but
actually you don't like that other
person or you don't think things should
be done that way like what do we do in
those situations and the wonderful thing
about triangle is so many people come to
the story and feel very personally
passionate about it but from completely
different points of view so people from
the labor movement feel very strongly
about it
New Yorkers feel strong about it people
who live in the East Village and Lower
East Side feels strongly women feel
strongly about it
the Jewish community was the
italian-american community the fire and
safety community and they all have a
personal investment in them so I decided
to start the I knew that they call it
the Santana was coming up in 2011 and I
wanted to create a way for all these
people to work together even if they
have very different beliefs and agendas
in a way that we could create the
Centennial together and really we winged
it at the beginning we started in 2008 I
just called a meeting with some people
who I thought might be passionate about
the triangle and
it was I would say like one and a half
two years of a very small number of
people some of whom are in this room
tonight who would get together like five
of us and we'd all kind of stare at each
other and go we think this is gonna work
well we don't even really know if this
is gonna work
and I think two things became very clear
to me that were vital to make this
success one was that everybody had to be
welcome there had to be no restrictions
no curation if you were passionate about
triangle you were in with us and that
was it and the second was that
decision-making power was given to the
people who did the work so there was
never like an administrative overview it
started with me being a benign dictator
until I reached the point where people
were tired of me being a benign
container and then we formed an
organizational structure but very far
into the project and I think that's a
lot of the time it was really hard to
get support for the project at first
because I honestly didn't know what they
were creating and it was only way into
it that I realized like people kept
saying what event are you doing or what
law do you want pass and it took time to
realize that what we were creating
actually was a platform for people to do
their own best work because that's
actually ultimately the most empowering
thing so by the end of the coal by the
centennial we had over 250 individuals
and organizations across the country
participating in doing events in their
local communities for the centennial and
we all we did was keep creating in
response to things that came up so I
started to notice on our Facebook page
people were starting to put these
extraordinary documents and pictures and
then I sort of had a little bit of a
lame idea oh we should have a timeline
or something so we
actually Facebook is not forever
somebody can make this forever and save
these things and fortunately I was put
in touch with Gabriel in Koscheck of Bou
SCADA and said something a little dense
about timelines I'd something like that
and their brilliance was the open
archive and I think that's a perfect
example how if you actually give up
control you get something much better
than you could ever do on your own
we started getting emails about
resources people having resources
knowing about young adult novels or
teaching plans and Andy here started
making a web page of all of those things
so that then people we could just send
people to where they could find stuff
then we wanted to work more closely with
the Union that was that organizes the
commemoration every year and it was
suggested that we maybe do something
with the 2009 Labor Day Parade and Andy
and Joel here said well let's go to the
Central Labor Council who I didn't know
who they were and he went there and we
created 146 shirtwaists that float on
bamboo poles one for each victim of the
fire and marched in the Labor Day Parade
and we were definitely the coolest thing
in the Labor Day Parade man but with the
family had a fire engine people who
could not walk the walk so and then when
the Centennial was coming you realized
there was people who were not in New
York who really wanted to participate so
we created the bells project where
people could email or put a comment on
the website the website um and say that
they were gonna ring a bell at 4:45 the
exact time the first alarm was set for
the triangle fire and we created a map
and if you said you were gonna ring a
bell for your great-aunt Mary who is a
garment worker I and you're gonna do it
in Chicago Illinois we put a pin on the
map for Chicago Illinois
and if you clicked on the pin it would
say that you were doing it if you're
great at Mary and we got like a couple
of hundred people participating across
the country in that and which led to I'm
gonna just show a little bit from the
Centennial my name is Edgar Rodney from
workers United thank you so much for
being here today 100 years ago on this
very day there was a fire where 146
young men and women lost their lives
because the dogs were lost and it
couldn't get out many of them died in
the fire escapes
many of them had to jump out the window
and it is our obligation and
responsibility to make sure we never
forget what happened to target and 46
workers representing the descendants
what a fantastic crowd you can testimony
and new meaning to Frances Perkins words
and I know because a whole to all of us
to rededicate our energies raise our
voices and become more active in the
pursuit of justice for all working
people so I think I'm gonna stop their
sweet time for questions